c'est pas la place d'une fille trop
jeune à Paris il y a trop de danger à
Paris et puis euh il faut pas venir à
Paris lorsqu'on est
[Musique]
naïve c'est par milliers qu'elles
arrivent chaque année dans notre
capitale elles ne viennent pas tenter
leur chance mais simplement travailler
car là où elles habitent il n'est pas
possible pour elles de gagner leur vie
ces jeunes filles de la campagne les
rurals comme on les appelle ont tout
quitté leurs familles leurs amis leurs
villages qu'elles aiment et dès leur
arrivé à Paris surgissent devant ell de
grave problème ce du logement et de la
solitude dont elles ignoraient l'acé
avant de quitter leur foyer et qu'il va
leur falloir résoudre de toute urgence
le problème de l'emploi
enfin la plupart d'entre elles après
leur certificat d'étude sont allés à
l'école ménagère aussi dès lors arrivé à
Paris se dirige-t-elle le plus souvent
vers le métier d'employés de maison
d'autres les plus débrouillardes
peut-être réussissent à se placer dans
les bureaux il est difficile de
s'adapter à la vie parisienne quand on
arrive d'un village de 300 habitants si
bien que les jours de congé ces jeunes
filles les passent souvent seules dans
leur chambre de bonnes ou au foyer où
elles habitent à moins qu'ell ne
connaisse la permanence rurale 27 rue
Cassette ou entre jeunes filles de la
campagne on se retrouve pour discuter de
ses problèmes et tâcher de les résoudre
moi j'ai eu tout de suite une chambre
venant à Paris mais je savais pas de
jouris
je savais même pas que j'allais venir
travailler je savais rien moi la
question s'est pas posée dem j'aiéta
employé une maison ma chambre s'est
trouvé été trouvée tout de suite c'est
ça c'est bien pour les employés de
maison elles ont une chambre directement
comme ça oui memoiselle mesemoiselle
d'où venez-vous de l'immaculé de
saint et vous mademoiselle de Biar de
près de saint-séri de Nère près de tour
de l'avoir manger à 25 km d'Amien on cô
de tu çainerie la maenne et il y a
combien d'habitants dans votre village
650 465 habitants 160 environ que
faites-vous à Paris où travaillez-vous
je travaille dans un atelier chez juin
chi je fais la couture flou je suis
seconde main qualifié je suis employé de
bureau oui et vous tapz à la machine
vous j'apprends vous apprenez à tap la
machineends le matin et le soir je suis
employée de maison oui mais je
suis la le principal de mon travail et
la cuisine vous êtes une bonne
cuisinière si on veut qu'est-ce qui vous
a appris qu'est-ce qui vous a appris à
faire la cuisine j'ai fait 3 ans d'école
familiale j'ai passé mon CAP je je suis
partie comme pays de maison à Paris je
suis dans les bureaux quoi enfin je
m'occupe de la comptabilité mais vous
avez appris déjà la comptabilité non
j'avais pas appris mais alors c'était
surtout une mise au courant et vous ne
pouviez pas trouver une place dans le
dans le petit village où vous étiez aux
environs tout près
ce n'est pas en province on ne paye pas
le prix qu'on paye à Paris combien
gagnez-vous par mois 50000 je gagne
30000 francs par mois et pourquoi
avez-vous quitté votre village et votre
famille je suis venue travailler à Paris
pour me pervectionner de mon travail
qu'est-ce que vous faisiez à
immaculé je faisais de la
couture j'allais en journée vous alliez
en journée et ça ça vous plaisait pas
je voulais travailler à mon compte et je
voulais pour cela me
perfectionner est-ce que vous gagnez
beaucoup d'argent quand vous travaillez
à votre compte je n gagné pas de Tra et
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
vous êtes mé à Paris oui et pourquoi
venu travailler à Paris parce que il y a
absolument rien là-bas pour travailler
160 habitants j'ai 5 frères et qu sœurs
alors nous pouvions pas vivre tous sur
la ferme car c'était trop petit c'était
ce n'est pas assez rentable pour tous je
suis venu à Paris à cause des de mes
parents je ne pouvais pas rester chez
moi vous ne vous entendiez pas avec vos
parents non ça n'allait pas du tout
est-ce que vous regrettez votre village
oh oui beaucoup j'ai eu beaucoup de mal
à m'habituer à Paris ça été très dur
mais alors j'étais obligé de me
raisonner autrement vous avvez
absolument besoin de gagner votre vie
oui puis c'est-à-dire à la vache je
seraiiss je ne sais combien de temps
sans trouver rien du tout ou alors
j'aurais trouvé une une place peut-être
peut-être d'employer une maison mais
alors moi ça ne me convient pas du tout
du tout et que représente pour vous
alors cette permanence rurale où vous
venez si
souvent elle représente un milieu où on
peut se retrouver en famille un milieu
où on est on est bien accueilli où on
peut discuter ensemble divers problèmes
et vous êtes satisfaite de ce métier
dans le poier de maison je dois dire pas
tellement non j'aimerais changer
j'aimerais sortir de là qu'est-ce que
vous aimeriez faire parce que j'aiaimis
beaucoup faire du dessin de mode c'est
ce qui m'est resté de l'école du Centre
d'apprentissage mais vous avez suivi des
cours j'ai suivi des cours l'année
dernière il y a de ans maintenant et
pourquoi ne continuez-vous pas et c'est
le manque de temps parce qu'il faut
beaucoup de temps et puis si on est
fatigué si je je cours le soir pour
attraper avoir un cours du soir de 8 à
10 il faut que je cours faut que je
planque tout et vite et je ne trouve
plus on a plus l'inspiration elle
vientnent pas tout de suite comme ça
quand vous avez des congés qu'est-ce que
vous faites le samedi et le dimanche
vous ne travaillez pas alors que ce que
vous faites euh le samedi maintenant je
suis des cours je fais des cours de quoi
des cours de coupe de coupe pour vous
perfectionner encore et alors et le
dimanche alors qu'est-ce que vous faites
le dimanche le dimanche je sors souvent
seule je vais à la permanence RA le soir
vous sortez seul et où
[Musique]
allez-vous vous allez au cinéma vous
allez non je pas au cinéma vous vous
promenez dans la rue vous vous visitez
Paris je visite oui qu'est-ce que vous
avez vu à Paris
je vais été voir le Louvre je reste à
Paris en fait je vais quelque fois chez
mes parents et quand vous êtes à Paris
le dimanche vous êtes à Paris alors
qu'est-ce que vous faites de votre
dimanche comment le passez-vous vous
avez au cinéma au théâtre non non non
non alors qu'est-ce que vous faites avec
qui sortez-vous oh avec une jeune fille
du foyer une jeune fille du foyer qui
est de la campagne comme vous oui c'est
ça et vous vous aimeriez sortir avec une
jeune parisienne oh pas spécialement non
pourquoi parce que vous je trouve pas
tellement de différence là sur ce point
alors qu'est-ce que vous faites vous
sortez avec ces jeunes filles qu'est-ce
que vous faites ben on va voir d'autres
filles ou bien on se promène on a été
une fois à versaill vous ne vous êtes
pas allé d'amitié avec une employée une
jeune ouvrière si avec plusieurs j'ai
j'ai fait des sorties nous sommes allés
à divers endroits de Paris vous entendez
bien avec les jeunes parisiennes euh ce
ce sont des employés de maison en
général quand une amie se trouve alors
on sort ensemble mais autrement je sors
pas je suppose que dans le bureau vous
travaillez doitil y avoir des jeunes
filles parisiennes mais c'est-à-dire
elles ont leur chez soi alors on se
préoccupe pas beaucoup les unes des
autres ah bon vous n'avez pas noué les
relations avec elles c'est-à-dire on
partle pendant le bureau elles arrivent
à l'heure moi j'arrive à l'heure on s'en
va on arrive c'est c'est la navette quoi
vous allez au bal quelque fois oui ça
m'arrive d'aller au bal quel et ça vous
plaît entre les deux c'est c'est pas la
même
ambiance qu'à la campagne à la campagne
on on connait tout le on est en famille
tandis
que à Paris c'est pas pareil on trouve
des visages nouveaux quelque fois des
visages qui qui sontquiétants inquiétant
oui qu'est-ce que vous pensez des jeunes
parisiennes est-ce que vous estimez
qu'elles sont différentes de
vous non dites-moi Marie José que
pensez-vous des jeunes filles de Paris
qui habitent Paris alors les Parisiennes
est-ce que vous les sentez différentes
de
vous les vraies parisiennes je sais pas
et les jeunes
gens moi je trouve puis il y en a qui
sont un peu
bêcheur mais
alors est-ce que vous épouseriez un
Parisien oh non alors loin de là et
pourquoi parce que ou alors on sait
jamais faut pas dire fond de son nom
mais et que pensez-vous des jeunes gens
à Paris est-ce que vous fréquenter les
jeunes gens à Paris non je les fréquente
pas vous n'avez pas envie de sortir avec
eux vous vous marierez pourtant un jour
je
suppose non est-ce que vous aimeriez
vous voudriez est-ce que vous aimeriez
épouser un Parisien un jeune
parisien moi je crois pas dites-moi que
pensez-vous les garçons à
Paris je sais pas est-ce que vous
souhaiteriez épouser un jeune parisien
ah oui prou pas oui vous préféreriez un
jeune parisien un garçon de votre
village oh non pas un garçon de mon
village pourquoi oh parce que c'est tous
des cultivateurs moi je veux pas marie
avec un cultivateur et pourquoi parce
que j'aime pas ce métier là vous ne
voudriez pas être fermière ah non les
parents le semble ça suffit ah bon alors
qu'est-ce que vous reprochez à ce métier
alors bon c'est trop dur est-ce que vous
retournerez un jour dans votre pays oh
j'espère bien est-ce que vous pensez
vivre à Paris vous établir à Paris oh
non je ne pense pas c'est-à-dire je ne
voudrais pas non plus m'établir dans mon
pays c'est trop petit puis il y a aucun
débouché mais alors je voudrais
m'établir dans la ville voisine par
exemple à la Val là c'est bien ce serait
l'idéal pour moi j'aime beaucoup être à
la campagne que j'aimerais avoir
une je sais pas un emploi mais ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas possible la campagne
quel conseil donneriez-vous à une jeune
fille qui voudrait quitter son village
et venir s'installer à Paris travailler
à Paris bah qu'elle sache d'abord où
elle va travailler et qu'elle s'assure
d'avoir un logement d'abord que qu'elle
aille un métier précis et puis
qu'elle sache ce qu'elle veut et
s'entend si elle est part comme employé
une maison qu' elle sache les conditions
qu'elle apprend enfin qu'elle a droit je
dirais à ces jeunes filles surtout ne
viens pas trop jeune à Paris pourquoi
parce
que c'est pas la place d'une fille trop
jeune à Paris il y a trop de danger à
Paris et puis euh il faut pas venir à
Paris lorsqu'on est naïve il faut avoir
de l'expérience quand on arrive à Paris
etzexpérience mais c'est-à-dire je suis
très jeune mais je suis bien débrouillé
quand même le conseil que je pour les
c'est
d'être de vraiment savoir où elle va ne
pas partir d'avoir une adresse précise
de un travail même précis qu'elle sache
ce ce qu'elle veut qu'elle ne reste pas
dans pourquoi parce qu'elle risque de se
trouver seule d'arriver seule dans Paris
sans tout démunie sans chambre sans sans
argent quelquefois et c'est terrible
pour et c'est terrible c'est la parce
que à Paris on ne peut pas se sentir
plus seul on peut pas être plus seul
dans tant de
monde
[Musique]